walk down your High Street look at the
shops and you know who owns them who
owns fing skyscrapers in Canary wolf who
owns a supermarket who owns a shopping
center you know what I mean who owns the
restaurants the pubs you know it's a lot
of it is ownership of commercial wealth
and the these guys what they look like
is usually they are families that have
been wealthy for a long time it's they
have their own sort of teams of
accountant which they call Family
offices and they just own all of this
stuff basically on paper they own the
stocks they own the shares they own a
ton of debt so that they own your
mortgage they own the government debts
when you pay your taxes the interest
goes to them um and work is meaningless
to them because they will make from
their assets you know and I want people
to understand this these are your cash
flows so when you go to tesos you some
guy owns tesos a big chunk of what you
pay it's just going his profits you know
what I mean all the people don't own
these things and they are owned by a
small number of extremely wealthy
families generally you don't see them
you don't hear of them you know their
kids go to eat and you know